Tiffany Haddish brings down the house
with her hilarious acceptance speech
mary j blige on her slayage from music
and now film plus get out start Dania
Kaluga is still shook by his own
breakout ear hey friends welcome back
denne here
now of course awards season is underway
and that means for folks like me goodbye
to my weekends but I am also genuinely a
geek when it comes to these things but
I'm not sure if you guys are so
obviously I'll be covering these award
shows up into the Oscars but it's also
my job to bring you what you want so
what do you want what stars or movies do
you care about you guys want some cool
behind-the-scenes stuff from these red
carpets let me know right now in the
comment section and I'll make it happen
for us alright in the meantime I'm gonna
throw a spotlight on the stars I care
about but wants to watch this award
season yesterday I shared why were
quickly becoming obsessed with call me
by your name star Timothy shallow made
he could become the youngest Best Actor
nominee in Oscars history and last night
he picked up another award at the New
York Film Critics Circle awards for his
breakthrough role and look we ran into
miss Tiffany Haddish who is not only
having her own banner year with girls
trip
but like Timothy in his movie she also
assaulted a piece of fruit on film in
2017 all right Tiffany stole the show
last night hitting the red carpet well
like that give it to him tip she ready
and inside she accepted the award for
best supporting actress but deserves a
second trophy for her speech alone
thankfully film critic Allison Wilmore
got the video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we love you - Tiffany all right now
another actress who was bussing up the
film world with her work mary j blige
now of course we know her as the queen
of R&B but now she's being recognized
for her role in mud bath I caught up
with her at the Palm Springs
International Film Festival about that
transition from music to film how
surreal is it for you to be here being
recognized for your acting it is surreal
oh so surreal um I'm just really humbled
by the whole thing that people loved the
performance that they are receiving me
as an actress it means so much I'm just
really really blown away
you're glammed up and looking gorgeous
tonight a far cry from your character on
mud bound I mean you mentioned that you
felt almost like it was a challenge that
you were just stripped away from all of
that why was that I mean it was a
challenge because I didn't realize I was
hanging on to so many things that made
me feel beautiful you know someone was
time to rip it away it was like oh wait
wait wait wait you know they were like
security blankets like lashes and wigs
and things like that so you know when
you're ready play a counter you like oh
you want to make a cue you don't want to
make a Audley so yeah I mean it was it
was it was a little hard but once I
surrendered you know she gave me some
confidence in the acting world to have
the title breakthrough actress it's like
I've done something amazing so I'm so
grateful I'm so thankful to God for just
allowing me to not be afraid you know at
what point did you realize I made it
like I'm here and I'm here to stay man I
was it was it had to be during a no more
drama album when I heard family affair
on a country station I was like what I
knew I'd done something
she sure did and speaking of doing
something big Danya kuya's life took a
huge turn once everyone saw him and get
out
he's also headed to the Golden Globes as
a first-time nominee and here's what he
really thinks of all the attention crazy
it's surreal
hey my Oscar weekend so the fact that it
still
being and it's still building it keeps
on getting bigger I'm like oh good that
we're really a part of this so I'm just
really happy for Judith and everyone a
part of its kind of like that we've done
something nice reading standing the test
of time clearly it means that women can
get off my back about going to unique
how are you preparing for that award
show are you excited and nervous I don't
see unites like I'm just chilled I'm
chilled I'm like taking it and trying to
enjoy you know saying cuz you don't know
that all anxious panting Keys just like
listen it's vibes we've worked hard it
was 23 days shoot we're still here let's
celebrate what we've done Jimmy because
it's probably the last time you will be
in the same room for a while so just
keep doing that
we'll see if Daniel takes the golden
glow' this Sunday on NBC and tomorrow
I'm taking you inside the home of the
Golden Globes for a preview of the big
show so stay tuned thanks for watching
you guys give us a little like in a
share and I'll see you tomorrow